hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna talk about
some Star Trek here Season 2 episode 6
review of the doomsday machine when were
top of war tears they're a video
requesting must do this one comes from
David Gandy today he said would you guys
be interested in reviewing an episode of
Star Trek the original series for the
September video requests he actually
changed it for our request calendar for
October you mention you'd like to have a
better knowledge of Star Trek so here's
a chance I know this won't get many
views we don't care about views no
obviously Alisa stakes off the Star Trek
community it won't the episode I have in
mind is the doomsday machine you can
comment anything about the episode but
what I have in mind is touch on the
quality of the 60s episodic TV in
general the writing and the allusions to
the Cold War William Windom guests our
performances Commodore Decker and the
director specific job with the episode
so yeah we watch this on Amazon Prime
the first three seasons of Star Trek are
available there to watch so that's just
a good tidbit for you to latch on to so
in this episode here's that this plot
description on Amazon get ready for it a
machine that destroys planets threatens
the enterprise which is not a planet so
it's even worse for them even worse for
them man they intercept a ship that is
just orbiting in space
well the personal life is Commodore
Decker whole crews been wiped out he's
the last man standing so in this series
of events they do their teleportation
think beam onto that ship they're like
hey Commodore Decker you're gonna stay
at the enterprise right now Spock's in
command right there we're gonna figure
out what to do with this ship meanwhile
this doomsday machine is kind of like a
robot alien it sucks you up just a
machine that's designed to suck in
planets and destroy them and use that
for fuel and it seems to have no other
use than to just destroy and it can't be
stopped because no one man's it and it's
completely shielded from the outside
it's kind of like that machine that is
used in the Star Trek reboot that Eric
Bana is using combined with the star
killer base that is introduced in the
force awakens a little bit of both
combined into
on slicing planet support I've never
seen any of the Star Trek episodes not
fully seen clips you know who hasn't at
this point several of the movies even
the ones with james t kirk an enterprise
wrath of god so this was pretty
interesting to see how gripping it would
be and i found this to be a rather
cinematic episode it's very well
composed as of course colorful as you'd
expect for the Star Trek show what I
found
engaging about it was when it starts off
it starts talking a lot about you know
that's technical jargons Star Trek
sci-fi yeah you're figuring out what the
monster-of-the-week is or what the story
of the week's gonna be for a lot of the
first-act yeah and there's a lot of
terminology being thrown around and as
it progressed though you start seeing
how this is really affecting the
characters I will talk about the things
you want us to talk about first David
this guests aren't performance when
William Windom what an interesting name
William Windom as Commodore Decker I
thought was great because he's a guy who
is desperate for a chance of redemption
because he feels responsible for the
crew dying you know this was pretty much
not his fault being someone who is in
charge of a ship you naturally feel like
these are my people and it's my
responsibility to keep them alive
because of that in the episode he takes
over the enterprise at one point did the
thing that I know schmuck would always
be obedient to which is rules man Spock
is a rule fall on him in the logic so he
takes over the enterprise for a bit and
he's like just attacking this doomsday
machine and everyone knows this ain't
gonna pan out well why would this work
out for any woman what was great about
this character was you could feel that
desperation in his performance the
entire time like even when he seemed
irrational even when you weren't
logically agreeing with his
decision-making it was always on the
spectrum of I could tell this guy is
desperate to get a chance of redemption
and that knowledge isn't laid out till
towards the end of the episode when he
sacrifices himself to try to give them a
shot when he steals one of those like
emergency ships and drives it in I
thought that was a very layered
performance and a cool nugget of detail
of what it must be like to be commander
of a Starfleet ship yeah I mean I liked
his performance a lot on the first
things that struck me about the episode
was that they held so much in his face
and when he's breaking down about the
death of his crew and what he had to do
and the fact that he made a call that a
lot of captains would make and it went
bad you know you really
I bought that grief a lot and I thought
he gave a lot of flavor to his
performance because there are hints at
that redemptive side but they're also
hints at madness and and mania I thought
of space dementia while we were watching
this part of me too because heat eaters
really nicely I think between villain
and kind of protagonist because when he
takes command of this starship
enterprise like he's kind of a scary
villain his character at that point
because he is so determined on this
mission is almost like Moby Dick he's
just like driven to destroy this thing
there were times in the kind of second
act of the episode where I would get a
little pulled out simply because they
fired on that thing so many times and he
just never ever even acknowledged that
this is just not working you know so at
that point I did kind of get frustrated
by that but overall I thought his
performance was really terrific and I
loved that in a show that has so many
iconic actors in such an iconic ensemble
there was this other guy who was a guest
actor for the episode he has a big
impression and who makes the world feel
bigger because he's a part of Starfleet
they have to kind of war with their
politics you know to get through this I
like the structure of this episode a lot
because you have Kirk you know he's the
commander of the enterprise and then
he's not even on the enterprise or 95%
of the episodes on this other ship
trying to get it to for minimal repairs
with Scotty so that way they could just
get it moving because the original plan
was just a to--it and what was great
about it was you do get a really good a
specific look on dynamics and relations
with all the crew members and which
position better suits everyone and who
to entrust like when Spock is in charge
of the ship what I thought was cool was
they never took a break to do like
expositional emotional moments it was
always about the situation at hand this
immediate situation yet you would see
the emotions come out of the characters
and how they're reacting to the
situation like like when Commodore
Decker takes over the ship bones it
won't have it bones is like yeah
because of the way Spock's mind operates
being a Vulcan that's not that fly
logics in the rules yeah exactly
I really appreciated through this
episode also just the the ensemble of
that because it's cool to see Spock
have to war back and forth with him
logically and this episode I thought did
a nice job turning things into
contextual thrills or a contextual
tension because a lot of this episode is
just them warring back and forth
ideologically figuring out whether or
not to fight you know yeah and there's
so much that's played in the proximity
of time and got people working on to the
holodeck you've got people working on
you know the phasers but that's why I
thought the structure was cool is
because putting Kirk away really gives
you a chance to see what the rest of the
crew is really like without their leader
there and how they entrust one another
so when you're watching how they're
handling things and they can't get in
touch with Kirk I love the moment when
Kirk gets on whatever the narrator
accounts are they're walking space
walkie-talkies and it's like you're the
maniac who's gonna get the enterprise
killed and he's like put Spock on
showing how integral it is that the
right team is there that goes beyond
regulations it goes beyond positions of
command that it's really about who the
characters are and who the people are in
their relationships because that's when
you know who to trust and in this
situation of crises yet by the end of
this episode
you still reaffirm who your star of the
show is who your leader is when Kirk is
able to save the day with a calculated
risk decision of blowing up the ship
he's on inside of well I can only
describe as the Eye of Sauron it happens
blowing up the ship in there assuming
for the most of the episode the
enterprise gang was the one handling it
but without Kirk and then by the end of
it it's Kirk's ultimate leadership
decision to bring it back full circle to
know this is why he's captain this is
why he's the leader hurt yeah because of
this decision-making and I love that
when he comes back on to the enterprise
that high-stakes scenario of three to
one it's gonna blow up we got to
teleport him back onto the enterprise I
love the response of how no ones like
you did it captain yeah
Spock just saying welcome back aboard is
just perfect showing you that this is
just what they expect out of Captain
Kirk
they wouldn't expect anything less out
of this guy too
put his life on the line to that degree
that speaks to that little line of
dialogue I think you worry about your
miracles I'll worry about mine you get
that sense that they are this
extraordinary team who's used to you
know their effectiveness together but
what I appreciated I guess a lot about
what this episode did in isolating Curt
from the rest of the team and all that
you see a lot of modern movies and a lot
of things like this that have like a
crew and a badass leader I really felt
that this crew could take care of
themselves with him stranded and I
thought that he demonstrated also amount
of resourcefulness it's like I feel like
when they rebooted Star Trek into the
new movies there's that aspect where
Kirk is that rebellious badass and not
the Decker represents that really but I
thought in this episode I thought you
had a nice clash of different kinds of
leadership though I'm just gonna take
control I know what to do
follow my lead and we're just gonna
shoot this thing and I think that is
favored a lot in stories like this
especially now and I thought it was a
nice contrast with Kirk because you see
the Kirk is willing to take those rash
decisions that do go beyond protocols
and ranks and whatnot when it's
necessary but he's also very much
trusting of his team of the advice of
others and the interesting thing about
this episode is that the solution
wouldn't have happened if this hadn't
happened it's like if Decker hadn't
gotten desperate ran off and grabbed
that little pod and flown into it I
don't necessarily think that would have
happened and they probably would have
had the thing II tried roll and go back
to Starfleet and they would have lost
even more lives and so in that moment -
there's that beautiful extra redemption
of you have that gray area that this
guy's kind of mad now it's kind crazy
but Kirk even says we're gonna make his
death mean something and yeah I don't
know I just thought this episode had a
lot of dramatic layers that were nice
and far as evil machines go it's a funny
design because I think it's you know
it's like super simplistic it looks like
a cornucopia or like a worm or something
and yet it was oddly effective somehow
yeah yeah I'm a suspect I think on its
close-up shots - yeah I was most
impressed with that you see that big
game nowadays it's kind of in Reverse
when you're further away the better it
looks now the closer you are it looks
weirder but with this it was in Reverse
they had this like really epic shot at
the end when Kirk is putting the ship
inside before they can successfully
teleport them out
it's like this close-up on the flames
inside of it which I thought was
beautiful and as far as the allusions to
the Cold War they were right on the nose
I was like okay what subtle hints I am I
looking for I don't know they're pretty
direct about it talking about these sort
of doomsday destructions and the irony
of having to use some type of h-bomb in
and of itself within the ship that Kirk
used to destroy another massive
destructive thing which I thought was an
interesting note I just picked up on
that yeah I mean I kind of took that as
the fallout from these arms races and
yeah the idea that he touches on is
saying that blowing this up this way and
kind of using a nuke to nuke another
nuke basically it's the first time we've
used this for something constructive and
yeah they touch on that idea of we have
these weapons that we built that we've
threatened each other with that could
just obliterate both of us at the same
time you know in terms of the Cold War
I'm not like an expert on it but I could
definitely feel those sorts of tensions
that threat of the unknown and the just
super devastating destructive force you
know and what happens if we wipe
ourselves out and this thing is still
just out there doing its thing you know
and and the endless fallout that could
happen from that because it's just gonna
keep spreading and eating people and I
thought in terms of full-on writing
films and TV shows from like 70s and
before we're pretty consistent in making
wonderful debate scenes yeah of really
arguing both sides to a debacle how do
we solve this or what's wrong with this
letting the emotions rise from trying to
make a decision and I thought that was
cool that that was pretty much most of
this episode yeah that's two very
different ideologies yeah yeah well
David thanks for introducing us to our
very first Star Trek episode we will
never watch another Star Trek episode
again this is all I needed to see but I
will watch that Quentin Tarantino Star
Trek movie because that's when I know
Star Trek will be the absolute best that
could ever be definitely people getting
blown out of doorways with big exploding
gushing blood those red shirts man live
long and let the force be with you
hey guys what's your favorite episode of
Star Trek comment below or favorite
movie from Star Trek or your favorite
Battlefield Earth mystery subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bow thank you David again I hope the
martial arts is treating you well I
appreciate all the advice on all the
enemas I've been talking with John
lately about getting a hydro colonic
cleanse
I like your enema vise a lot and hey you
just keep on rocking Gandy keep on
rocking I'll see you in the patreon
messages you sexy bastard you